today
today i would like to talk about
freenomics
and language learning
freenomics is a term
coined by i think his name is chris
anderson
who explains how
in the modern world the cost of
distributing information on the internet
is so cheap
that some basic
economic
terms of reference a basic paradigm has
has changed or is changing
that the model increasingly will be that
things many things will be free
because the additional cost
of servicing a thousand people rather
than servicing 10 people is so low
that
in many cases if you can get one percent
of your users to pay for
a premium service
99 of the users will be able to use
a very useful service although a scaled
down range of services free of charge so
that the bulk of people
using a range of services
or products on the internet will in fact
be free users
those free users are in a sense
the marketing and the promotion
investment in order to attract that one
percent of users who want a premium
service
we have an online language learning
system called link
we use the inter the internet i didn't
build the internet i didn't invest in
the internet
the additional cost
for us to use the internet or for our
users to access link via the internet is
zero
because they already have
the internet in place which they are
using for a range of other purposes
paying their
utility bills or sending each other
sending their friends email so the cost
to use
what we offer the distribution cost is
zero
now let's get back to language learning
traditionally in language learning
people would either go to school which
can cost anywhere cost anywhere from
hundreds of dollars to over a thousand
dollars a month
or if they were self-learners
they would go and buy books and i guess
i have been a traditional
language learner i have lots of books at
home for a while i was learning korean
so here is a book it's a big thick book
beginning two that means there's a
beginning one and there's intermediate
and so forth um here's another book that
i bought on korean
i mean look at this whoops that's the
back look at the size of this book it's
a great thick book
it really doesn't get you very far but
it's some assistance okay i buy books on
russian here
um
i normally prefer smaller books this is
one colloquial korean that i bought i
bought a colloquial russian
i even bought
a
teach yourself russian and part of the
reason for that is that i have found
that it's often very useful to cover the
same ground
via different books i i'm not a great
believer in the grammatical explanations
i'm looking for content all the time so
i have in the past bought these books
nowadays that's no longer necessary
and
i make allusion to that in my book which
i wrote quite some years ago
the linguist a personal guide to
language learning it was by the way
translated into chinese it was published
in china
and the main point there was
to explain
that language learning
is something that is very individual
it's very personal
that a heavy emphasis on on listening
and reading to individual content can be
very effective provided you have the
right attitude
and in that book i spoke and this is
five six years ago about the internet as
a community
of a convivium
of learners who are learning from each
other and helping each other that world
is now
becoming more and more of a reality
uh today for example to study a language
i no longer go out and buy
books uh what i need is two things first
of all i need this
which is an ipod shuffle fifty dollars
you can also get a larger ipod if you
want i have it with me all the time
and
of course because i don't necessarily
understand what i hear
i go to link
where
there is a large library of audio
content
and text content or i can import content
from a variety of sources so essentially
what has happened is that
this little device
and whoops and and this
and the internet have replaced all these
books and of course it's much much
cheaper
so
we at link we want to take advantage of
this we want to offer this opportunity
for people to learn on their own
certain things have to happen for that
to be successful
first of all we have to make link
as attractive a place as possible for
people to learn so we have to continue
to invest in improving our functionality
our
ease of navigation on the site the
explanations that we provide and we are
continuing to do that our developers are
working constantly to improve our
functions and to make it easier and more
fun for people to use
the second thing is going back to the
original point
that we have to establish a range of
services
and functions
that are a
attractive to our free users so that
they will keep coming and tell their
friends
but b that we have a range of elite
services
specialized services that are
sufficiently attractive so that a small
percentage of our users will actually
pay
us for those additional services
and those people
will find those services sufficiently
attractive
and
sufficiently
attractive not only in terms of
functions but in terms of the cost in
other words inexpensive so they don't
mind the fact that they are in fact
supporting the other 99 of people who
are using the site for free
so that's the direction we have to go
now the 99 of people who are using the
site for free actually are helping us
because they are spreading the word
about link so that if we can continue to
increase the number of people who use
the site for free and that that if out
of that group we continue to get a
certain percentage
who are happy to pay for these premium
services
then that's the model that will make us
ultimately successful
the beneficiaries of course are the
language learners or those language
learners who who are self-motivated and
who can understand our model
so i will be doing some more uh podcasts
uh
on this subject talking about some of
the other aspects some of the other
pieces
of the uh link
model
and i look forward to questions and
comments that uh that you may have
thank you for listening